oh hi sweetie you're just just in time  for dinner  hey I do and bloody how was the field  trip I don't feel well I'm gonna go to  sleep well you will never buy no thanks  had a bike or did you get some pictures  Peter uh I got a crash everything's fine  sano ha  you  [Music]  [Music]  weird  [Music]  either yes are you alright  ah I'm fine any better this morning any  change change yeah big change right  [Music]  okay  [Music]  meet I thought you were sick  I got better see my god you have means  anything if you got your lunch money I  got it hey Michelangelo don't forget  we're painting the kitchen right after  school got a sure thing Uncle Ben don't  start without me and don't start up with  me  teenagers raging hormones they never  change  you